[Música]
buenas tardes del mundo muchas gracias
por venir somos yo margarit y ustedes
somos fundadores de tu 6 y hoy les vamos
a explicar nuestro viaje
desde que nacemos normalmente se nos
marca unas directrices hacia un camino
bastante tradicional desde que comemos
que estudiamos que deportes hasta un
poco con que nos acabamos relacionando
no supongo que es porque nuestros padres
normalmente aunque es lo mejor para
nosotros
pero hay un momento
cuando lo piensas te das cuenta de que a
lo mejor estás viviendo un camino que tú
no has escogido
y nosotros hoy no estamos aquí para
deciros que el camino tradicional es ni
mejor ni peor sino de que hay muchos
otros caminos
si nos llegan a decidir hace cinco años
conocimos con este personaje que
estaríamos aquí haciéndote héctor que se
nos reiríamos en la cara y que nos lo
dijera y nosotros con ellos
la verdad que sí
[Música]
yo en mi caso era el bala perdida
por bueno por
fracaso escolar no era el mejor
estudiante de todos he ido a tres
colegios cuatro universidades
supongo que por qué
no era lo que me gustaba o no me sentía
cómodo cuando estaba en clase no sentía
que estaba aprovechando mi tiempo y
tenía muchas ideas en la cabeza y no me
podía concentrar
así que decidí
dejarlo deje la universidad a mi segundo
año y empezar otro camino
en mi caso así que me había centrado
mucho en los estudios y para mí no
entrar en mi universidad pompeu fue un
fracaso personal muy grande pero como
siempre al final um
una puerta que se cierra abre otra
puerta y justo fue el momento donde todo
el auge del social media está empezando
hace 45 años y tuve la suerte de meterme
en ese mundillo a que ni los influences
se conocían ni la gente ni nosotros
hemos lo que lo que está pasando y justo
empezamos empezamos a crecer empezamos a
viajar y nada pues empecé a crear mi
propio camino las marcas empezaron a
contactarnos nos empiezan a enviar ropa
nos empezaban bueno parecía todo idílico
yo aún me acuerdo y volvía de eeuu que
fui a estudiar allí el bachillerato y al
llegar acabé en una universidad que no
escogí ni yo los que son mis padres por
mí y estaba en macroeconomía me acuerdo
como si fuera ayer en primera línea
porque profesor me quería en primera
línea
y yo estaba ahí mirando instagram tal
debajo de la mesa la mente se hablaba y
explicaba cosas y de repente veo a biel
en filipinas y en clase violen filipinas
bien en filipinas viajando conociendo a
gente súper cool super interesante ha
ganando pasta ropa gratis y en clase
y bueno y lo que parecía tan bonito para
ayudar que tenía esta imagen idealizada
para mí en ese momento empecé a tocar de
realmente se me vino todo abajo
empezaron todas mis comparaciones todas
mis inseguridades con todo el social
media y empecé realmente a tomármelo
como una cosa que ya no disfrutaba y
todo lo que desde fuera se veía como un
éxito idealizado un éxito que para mí
era banal porque yo no me sentía auto
realizado al final cuando te haces de ti
mismo producto te acabas volviendo pues
a que vas cogiendo inseguridades que no
sabía ni que tenía me acuerdo de estar
con mi madre
en casa sentado en el sillón y llorando
diciendo pero por porque me está pasando
esto pero pero sí porque si lo tengo
todo en teoría como puede ser que me
esté pasando esto
desde pequeños siempre hemos sido los
dos un poco culos inquietos como dicen
nuestros padres
hemos tenido mil ideas
demasiadas demasiadas a lo mejor no
hemos tenido mil ideas mis cosas que
hacer siempre queríamos hacer cosas sea
por lo que fuera yo de hecho me acuerdo
que bien con 15 años
y vendía entradas de discoteca
a una discoteca de tardes no acuerdo
cual pero viera y vendiendo entradas
discoteca y estoy seguro que no era ni
por el dinero sino por el simple hecho
de quiero tomar mis propias riendas y
hacer algo con mi vida igual que en mi
caso yo siempre era un iluminado y decía
me monta una aplicación veamos la otra
aplicación en dos años hoy él siente
steve jobs y hablando con developers tal
y estas ideas no me llevan a ningún lado
tantas ideas tantas ideas que un día nos
iluminamos y realmente decidimos hacer
el viaje que cambia un poco nuestras
vidas pero
fue un viaje desde las vegas hasta pan
frings en un antiguo autocaravana esa
pieza la de 'breaking bad' donde hacen
todo el tema pues en eso
y estuvimos 10 días allí fue donde nos
inspiramos y realmente con generamos
entre nosotros también y realmente
queríamos pasar nuestras ideas a
proyectos y no realmente no sabíamos
cómo hacerlo
justo antes de ir como buenos
influencias nos estamos preparando
nuestros outfits para disfrutar porque
nos gusta mucho y no encontramos las
joyas que estábamos buscando
y decidimos pero como puede ser que
realmente a lo que veíamos que había una
demanda y que nadie estaba suplementando
esa demanda y decidimos pues ir y una
vez allí encontramos un par de sitios
porno había lo que nosotros estamos
buscando que era una marca con el
espíritu salvaje que
así que de repente un día
me veo en el aeropuerto de las vegas
el personaje también a mi lado los dos
con botas de tacón de cowboy pantalones
acampanados
cinturón de hebilla grande
chaleco camisa de cuello alto gafas
sombrero y estamos en las vegas'
[Música]
y lógicamente la primera noche nos vamos
al casino y lógicamente perdemos nuestro
dinero
pero este día
ganamos algo mucho más importante
ganamos una dirección hacia un viaje que
realmente cambió nuestras vidas
un viaje que supuestamente era desde las
vegas hasta pan springs que fue como el
momento donde nos descubrimos vimos lo
que queríamos nos inspiramos incubamos
la idea
pero ese viaje no acabó los ángeles
hoy dos años más tarde este viaje sigue
se llama tu 6 y es una comunidad de más
de 200.000 personas por todo el mundo en
más de 100 países pero lo más heavy es
que tenemos un equipo que llega cada
mañana a nuestra oficina feliz que llega
motivado que llega contento que tiene
ganas de trabajar y esto hace que todas
nuestras ideas locas se hagan realidad
y entonces nos preguntamos
porque esta idea se ha podido realizar y
todas las otras ideas que hemos tenido
no llevaron a ningún lado
vimos que
lo principal es que nuestra pasión por
la idea era desproporcionada
y que realmente esto sumado a que había
una necesidad de mercado y también que
nosotros tenemos la necesidad realmente
personal de inculcar todas nuestras toda
nuestra creatividad todo nuestro adn
instructivo todo lo que habíamos
aprendido durante esos años en el mundo
de social media en una propia idea
la pasión hizo que dejemos aquí dejamos
de lado toda la vida influencers y que
nos arremangamos los brazos y nos
metiéramos en el barro del mundo
emprendedor
juanillo llamando
nueve de la tarde en viernes
a nuestros proveedores que no teníamos
ni idea de una
de una industria que nosotros no
conocíamos montando collares en el
despacho de mis padres hasta las 3 de la
mañana
cajas cosas que cualquier persona cuando
se plantea realizar un proyecto se va a
encontrar con ello pero que nosotros lo
que lo que hemos visto que realmente
haga hace que puedas hacerlo en realidad
es que la pasión y realmente estar
apasionados y enamorados el proyecto es
lo que hace que tú puedes superar
cualquier barrera
cuando lanzamos el proyecto y vimos que
a lo mejor esto iba un poco en serio y
nos planteamos que queríamos ser pero
sobre todo como queríamos hacerlo
no veníamos de una de un pasado
tradicional a nivel estudios formación
así que no queríamos para nada una
empresa tradicional no queríamos unas
oficinas tradicionales no queríamos
un punto de venta tradicional no
queríamos forma de contratar a las
personas fuera tradicional no queríamos
una empresa tradicional lo que queríamos
todo disruptivo porque es cómo nos
sentimos
queríamos que lo que dice ayudan que la
creatividad
que se inundará por toda la empresa y
que cogiera las riendas de todo cuando
hacemos el harding preguntamos más el
que has hecho que no el donde es
estudiado
por ejemplo también empezamos nuestro
propio canal de youtube para explicar un
poco también a las entrañas de la
empresa y que la gente pudiera vivir
desde dentro lo que es montar un
proyecto o como por ejemplo montar una
vending machine o una máquina
expendedora para que escupa joyas y que
no sea una tienda normal bueno
una y de hoy en un momento en un momento
clave para la empresa que juntamos a
todos a todo nuestro equipo a todos
nuestros amigos toda la gente nos había
apoyado nuestro proyecto y la juntamos
el verano pasado para que realmente
tuviera una experiencia a tu seis al
final nosotros tenemos una posición muy
privilegiada que es que hemos estado en
el lado de seròs influencer y en el lado
de ser una marca y ahí hemos entendido
un poco cuáles son las
pues cuál es la relación de las dos
cosas y cuáles son las necesidades y
creando esto intentamos que todo el
mundo se sentirá participe de tus seis
incluir a todo el mundo dentro de
nuestra creatividad como siempre
intentamos hacer en las campañas
y nosotros consideramos que fue un éxito
también a nivel personal y poder
agradecer a toda la gente que nos está
apoyando por hacer estas cosas
bueno
la madre de bien siempre siempre dice
que
que realmente vendemos joyas como excusa
para montar nuestras estas películas que
hacemos que es una excusa para disfrutar
para bueno para hacer todo lo que
hacemos
y bueno es una anécdota graciosa
pero mi padre en cambio a día de hoy
después de dos años aún no entiende nada
de lo que estoy haciendo
no es capaz de entenderlo
pero
con todo esto
hemos aprendido nos hemos dado cuenta
que teníamos una vida de influencers
idealizada y que al menos nosotros
nos hemos dado cuenta de que no nos
llenaba porque como que tenía un techo
nosotros teníamos demasiadas cosas de
aquí como para explotarnos a nosotros
mismos así que renunciamos a eso pero
como cada fracaso todo tiene una
oportunidad
pero lo más importante es que nos hemos
dado cuenta de que todas estas ideas de
las que hablamos
si realmente tú no estás profundamente
enamorado del proyecto no se van a
convertir en proyectos porque cuando
tienes un proyecto te encuentras con
tantos obstáculos que si no estás tan
enamorado no serás capaz de pasar estos
obstáculos no tendrás ni las ganas y las
fuerzas del tolo y nosotros estamos tan
tan tan enamorados que no somos capaces
de hacer cualquier cosa aunque parezca
imposible
pero después de todo estoy reflexionando
john y yo realmente que ha sido el éxito
para nosotros
éxito
los likes ni los pedidos ni los
seguidores ni los viajes
el éxito ha sido poder crear nuestro
propio camino a poder realmente
crear nuestra propia vida y crear un
proyecto que toda la gente que está
involucrada está igual que nosotros
como para realmente acabar disfrutando
del día a día que al final esto es de lo
que va de disfrutar el camino de
disfrutar el viaje y es un poco lo que
nuestros amap de todo esto que es
y ahora queremos que te preguntes cuál
es tu viaje
muchas gracias y enjoy the ride lighting